Hey,
what's going on is bill burn.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast from Monday,
October 22nd,
2018 what's going on? How are Ya? Oh,
it's almost the holiday season and
you'll be dooby do and Halloween and
thanksgiving. Don't forget
about them, but boy,
you slide into fucking
Hanukkah and Christmas. Right?
Halloween and Thanksgiving are
the fucking Joey bishop. And uh,
what was the other guy's name was,
what was the other guy that was in
the rat pack rule? Said Rod Laver
something. Crawford. I Dunno what the
fuck his name was. Cindy Crawford.
Cindy serum isn't a greater Cindy's
back on TV telling these old broads,
if they get to fog the fucking
serum and they don't have her,
a genetic is still somehow
going to look younger.
You know,
Miss, she honestly looks
like she's like fucking 30.
I'm going to get some Cindy's therom.
My hair is going to come back.
It's going to be all way B.
I'm going to get a fucking contract.
Was Chanel my stupid phone keeps
saying update apple ID settings.
It's not as stupid phone. I
apologize. Excuse me. I misspoke.
It's not a stupid phone. It's a smart
phone. Oh it's so fucking smart.
Every two seconds,
you know,
to diva up to update apple ID settings.
Some account services will not be
available until you sign in again.
So I keep signing in and there's some
sort of fucking code is supposed to send
me and I think I deleted it cause I
just saw some bullshit from Verizon.
You know like do you want to,
do you want to pay your bill online?
Okay.
You know what she optioned up to fucking
submit your DNA if you'd like with your
fingerprint so we can pass that on
to some fucking Russian mobster.
Okay.
Who is then going to buy a penthouse in
it and in fucking New York City for nine
zillion dollars and nobody's
going to give a shit.
Okay.
I want to, I want to
know why. Why? All right.
If I go to sit here supporting the tropes,
being American and all of that shit,
why these rich cons in this fucking
country can then turn around and sell real
estate to people that live in
countries that we have problems with.
Okay.
I don't want to get all 80 stand up here,
but what's the deal?
Day to day would fucking,
I swear to God,
if one of these jungle
gym fucking training,
Isis guys could somehow scraped together
fucking nine zillion dollars to buy a
fucking townhouse in Manhattan,
they'd sell it to them.
Okay.
No to have a fucking problem.
No one.
Well,
maybe would have a problem then and we
have fucking goal rate will go away real
quick. All right. You tell
him I go to New York City,
which I was just there.
I had a wonderful time.
I saw this fucking dude from Russia.
He bought three townhouses
on the upper east,
upper west side. Fucking things go
for like 2030 30 million of whack.
The fucking guy buys three side by side
is gutting all of them to tournament to
the biggest fucking
apartment in Manhattan.
Okay.
Here's the kicker. He, he
bought it for his ex wife.
My first thought was what killed
Jesus Christ set out. I shut her up.
Yeah.
Then are they get them at least
through fucking, you know,
Halloween and Thanksgiving before the
holiday season really fucking kicks in.
You spend all your, do you know, you know
what's funny about that? Fucking broad.
She probably still wants
something for Christmas too.
I'm trying to help you.
I can't fucking do a Russian accent,
but I can't imagine what the fucking,
you know good.
And God damn well if he doesn't go out
and get us some big shiny stupid fucking,
I mean,
how much of a fucking headache?
Well, she, this is ex wife. He
went out and bought her that.
Yeah.
I mean if I was just account, I'd be like,
he's still fucking banging or, I mean,
what's going on here? What do
we don't get ghetto. Get a one.
Boris,
what do you define a fucking tree?
Um,
yeah,
and I guess he doesn't get audited
because he saw him, I don't know.
It's a whole fucking thing is weird.
And then you'll see like, you know,
it'd be like some giant Goddamn building
and they'll be like the top fucking
nine floors for a cool $170 million.
Did we say cool
was sold to some fucking
person on mainland China.
Okay.
All these people. Okay. Janie's right.
You know what they're doing right?
That they're putting like dip,
doing something with the toys.
I forget what it was. Somebody told
me this one night in a bar, uh,
the guy was whispering,
he had one eyebrow, but he
really seemed to make sense.
They're doing some of the toys. Russia
is fucking with the elections, right?
Isn't that what I'm supposed to know?
We're supposed to say you're supposed
to repeat now that I'm in Hollywood.
I don't know. I don't even know
what the fuck I'm talking about.
All I know is it's very early in the
morning and I'm getting my podcast done
here before my,
uh,
my little cutie pie wakes up and I was
supposed to do it last night, but, um,
we ended up going out, went
out to breakfast, you know,
I hadn't seen it forever.
Right. And I was away from the family for
nine days. So we went out to breakfast
and,
uh,
when she came home for a nap and then
afterwards we went to this pumpkin patch
and it just fucking me
out, you know? I mean,
I could've come on and done a podcast,
but I wouldn't have been as funny.
Okay.
You know,
I wouldn't have been able to give you
all that vital information you need to
know about the country of
Russia and China. I mean, all
of that stuff was dead on.
You can go fact jacket@bill.com.
I've got all the facts to
fucking to back it up, right?
Um, I'm only kidding. Um,
if you're from Russia and you're from
China and you'd like to take your dirty
blood money and spread it around
here, then by all means, by all means.
Let's have after, after all this
suspicion about the last election,
let's have somebody from Russia
by three fucking townhouses,
right in the God damn.
Okay.
Fucking Manhattan. Why
don't, why don't we do that?
Why don't we have a fucking
commercial late at night? Okay.
That has a fucking knife, sharp and
a thing that's so God damn sharp.
Evidently you can sharpen a credit card
with it and cut a fucking pineapple and
half.
Why don't we fucking do that and ignore
our goddamn recent history and just have
that out on the market.
And then this on a red flag,
have something out there that can take
a fucking butter knife and have it go
through for a frozen fucking steak.
The commercial that
literally showing the thing,
I almost feel like fucking irresponsible
putting this information out on
sharpening a credit card.
Okay.
Then it looks slices of,
I dunno what it was,
went through a fucking shoe.
I love the thing that's just like,
we took this cerated fucking knife and
we fucking went across concrete and then
we stuck it in this fucking thing and
now you can cut your postman's fucking
shoe off with his foot still in it.
Once again,
I don't want to do 80 stand up here,
but how sharp is the fucking type data?
I was watching that commercial last night
with the lovely Nia and we were just
laughing our asses off.
Yeah,
going, I, I wouldn't want that in
my house. I wouldn't, I wouldn't be,
I wouldn't feel safe
with me fucking happen.
A knife that I cut the
fucking tip of my finger off.
God knows what some other lunatic,
okay.
No civilian needs a
knife that fucking sharp,
even though it's fucking a Dyson
concert and one of those cooking shows,
you know,
I just wondered if that fucking guy from
hell's kitchen ever realized how sharp
the fucking knives are of the people
that he's screaming and yelling at.
You know.
And I worked in enough fucking restaurants
being one when I was growing up to
realize that people who work in the
kitchen for the most part are not the most
stable fucking people,
fucking lunatics.
I used to work in this fucking restaurant.
One of the guys was on work release,
meaning at night he went back to jail.
He voices it dices you
can rob a bank with it.
Um, anyways, I'm so fucking happy to, uh,
I'm an old man now. People,
I can't, I can't go on the
road for that long, you know?
And now that I've took the time to build
a personal laugh and have something to
come home to, you know what I mean?
I miss all the varmints run around.
I'm a property taken out in slingshot
killing something before breakfast.
You know, it's one of my favorite things
to do. Go out in nature, breathe it in.
Feel the peace and Fuckin kill some skin.
It look around making sure
no other predators coming
around won't steal my Keel.
I'm in one time.
I sell this beautiful family of
squirrels right outside Mama.
Breck get my breakfast and milk.
Some are carved out without a permit
and a load bearing wall with
eight nobody to know that, right?
And I saw sue family squirrels and the
mother was handed a little baby a score,
a little fucking nut.
And right before it handed it to her,
I blew that thing's fucking brains out.
Made me feel like an American
mean. A little fucker was
coming down and you know,
I have a little bird feeder and they would
know enough that feeds for the birds.
All right? And I don't want to hear
nothing about no god. Damn Squirrel.
Ain't no fucking ain't fucking smart
enough to realize that bird food is bird
food and, and squirrel fruit is
squirrel food. And just reminded me,
you know, we're not sell that bird. I'm
not in me to ask this. And I was like,
what is this little beady and
motherfucker doing in, in the bird feed?
And I killed it in front of it's baby
squirrel to send a message to the other
squirrels. Sorry. Um, anyways.
Did Anybody Watch any, uh, what do, what
do, what do I want to talk about first?
You want to talk Formula One
racing Ui while you wait,
why won't you want to talk fucking f?
F1 You know what considering,
and it's always a weird call right now.
I just talked about killing
varmints in your fucking backyard,
which is very American, very
patriotic. Borderline a holiday,
right?
But I also talked about a Russian
and Chinese people buying fucking,
you know, top level fucking,
uh, real estate. Jesus. Bill.
Can he get it out once they bought
in America? All right, let, let's go.
F One f one oh Lewis Hamilton,
Louis the finger pointer Hamilton,
one of the great drivers of all time,
but oh,
does that guy liked to fucking point
fingers when he doesn't win a race?
Oh my God. He always goes, you know,
I don't know what happened. You know,
I don't really understand
what the strategy was there.
I'll have to find out about that.
But you know, racing is tough.
Okay.
He always does that.
Maybe that's why he's great.
It was a really, really,
really fucking exciting race. Lewis
Hamilton had the poll. All right,
the fucking race starts. Kimi
Raikkonen said, you know what?
I know I have more than a race since 2015
I think today's a good fucking day to
try to win one. And he comes to,
I don't even know what you know,
cause I didn't see any of the qualifying.
I fast forward through all the,
the grid lineups and shit.
I thought it was battle at first and
when I saw fucking Vettel spinout Yo,
I love about Vettel
federal and Kimmy raking.
I listen to a lot of guys
who drive emotionally. Yeah.
Sebastian Vettel was driving the way I
drive in fucking rush hour traffic ends
up spinning out, fucking up his car and
he just, you know, he doesn't wave and go,
I'm sorry. Just slams on
the gas. Like he's fucking,
Burt Reynolds spins the car
around and keeps driving. Yeah.
Okay.
Okay. The guy managed to get all the way
back up to the front of the field to the
point that Lewis Hamilton needed to come.
And second,
if he was going to win yet
another championship and you know,
its Lewis Hamilton just because,
you know, it's not like,
I don't fucking respect the
guy, but I, you know, I'm
new to this sport. One of my,
I'm gonna just gonna become
a Lewis Hamilton fan. Um,
I'm just going to start
watching college football.
And who's your favorite team on Alabama?
I'm a fucking doing that.
I'm going to refill it. You, um,
yeah you gotta go.
Contrarion so anyways, uh,
he had a chance everybody,
I think he fucking, yeah,
he pitted early,
like really early,
like on lap 12 of 56. I'm taking,
what the fuck is he doing?
There's no matter what he does,
those tires are gonna wear out.
So now he's in first place.
He's driving like a lunatic
because he's trying to get, guess,
get enough fucking space.
Um,
between him and everybody else,
specifically Sebastian Vettel because
if we basically, I don't know,
I don't know how many fucking points
he needed. I'm new to the sport,
but he basically could have
won the championship that day.
Okay.
So he's driving like a lunatic
wild trying to conserve as tires,
which never fucking works.
Right.
That's like staying in a relationship
because you know, you've got great sex,
but there's no love there.
Eventually. Yeah, you got to fucking,
you got to pull off. Just be
like, why, what are we doing here?
So it was fucking tars end up,
you know,
start blistering like
my shoulders in the sun.
They're like my ginger
freckled shoulders in the sun.
So any poles in.
And then the big thing is like fucking
Kenny get out of the pitch before battle
comes around so he can be in front of
them and he's got botox in front of them.
Valtteri Botox.
Right.
And you know Valtteri he's going to
fucking do whatever Louis wants him to do
because evidently he's the fucking
gimp on the Mercedes team. I mean,
that guy's given away literally a victory
this year to keep fucking Louis happy.
And Lewis is still walking
around going, yeah, you know,
I don't know what happened. They, what
do you mean? You know what happened?
What happened there is everybody's
catering to your fucking needs. Sorry.
You're gonna have to wait another week
before you win the fucking championship.
Okay.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Somebody get this guy some sparkly fucking
Kleenex over here. Right. So anyways,
he gets out of the pit before Vatal does.
It's so fucking exciting.
My wife's going like, wow, this is
really interesting. It's amazing.
I can't get her to get into football.
Probably cause again hit
each other anymore. Right.
But I think I might've got her into motor
sports. I said, come on. Yeah, I go,
this is fucking international.
Okay.
And we went with this. They have a race
in Monaco. People pull up in yachts.
Okay. Did, does human trafficking going
on in the bay is the cars are going by.
And of course this gets your
excited cause all she's seen,
you know what she likes, she liked with
Lewis Hamilton, got out of the car.
She goes, wow, he's really
into jewelry. You know, I had
her, I had her right there.
It's going to cost me a bunch
of fucking money. So anyways,
uh,
Max,
Max Verstappen whenever Lewis and starts
working his way up to the fucking field.
By the way, Daniel Card has fucking
nightmare of a season continues.
He's driving around,
he's having a great fucking time.
All of a sudden his car quits like
a fucking Prius in the left lane.
Remember that rumor?
The thing just fucking dies and he pulls
over and now he's just getting you to
see mom, we were driving for
fucking Renaud. Yes, next year.
Can anybody explain to me why that
guy isn't going to be driving for a
okay
for Ferrari next year?
Cause they were trying to suggest that
maybe Kimi Raikkonen it's not going to be,
I can't fucking believe how much
I might know about this sport.
I love it anyways,
so they get down to the final five laps.
Lewis Hamilton needs to pass Max
Verstappen the does that 11 enough,
you know, gap between him as far as like,
uh, you know, I think at that would've,
that'll come and forth maybe,
but with the points he would
have enough points to win
and you got to give it to veteran Ferrari.
They're fighting to the very end.
They're like, fuck these
fucking assholes. We're Ferrari.
All right. That's what everybody fucking
wants. They want a god Damn Ferrari.
And maybe if you're a little bit younger,
you want a Lamborghini. Okay. But really,
if you really look throughout history,
elegant styling power,
all of that,
you got to give it to Ferrari.
You just have to,
every kid had a fucking post magnum
Pi. Did he drive a Mercedes? No,
we did not.
He drove a Ferrari.
Okay.
People out there who got the first
hair plugs. Did they buy a Mercedes?
No, they did not. They bought a Ferrari.
I don't want, I'm talking about here. Um,
anyways, all I know is when you
go to those meek and fucking,
you watch those Mika car auctions,
it's not even like for
like actually Mercedes, uh,
vintage Mercedes and Ferraris there.
Then I even at that thing there, right.
That thing that Jay Leno goes to on
that golf course up by fucking, uh,
where the hell, I mean
that, that's like debts.
Like people know every nut and bolt on
the fucking car or they have enough money
to buy their ex wife fucking three
God damn townhouses stuck together in
Manhattan. Ex Wife, right? Pebble beach.
I mean those cars are so fucking nice,
so goddamn expensive.
They drive them onto the golf
course at pebble beach. You know,
like you go into the fucking Rosebowl.
Um,
so they, they, anyways, for,
I had a huge day. I feel, you
know, Kimmy raking in one,
his first, first, uh, since 2015,
Sebastian Vettel showing the
heart of a fucking line, you know,
you're going to have to fucking kill me
if you want to win this championship.
And uh,
I don't know,
I'd probably add the best
thing was watching Louis
Hamilton trying to pass past
max for staffing and Max for stamps and
holding them off. Right. For some reason,
by the way, ESPN get out of the
fucking car when that's going on.
You know, I, I, what the
fuck am I looking at here?
I'm in the garden or playing a video game.
How can I tell how close they are if I'm
fucking sitting in the God damn car and
I can't look in the side view mirrors,
they did it on the replay too. Anyways,
but I also love that Lewis Hamilton,
like how we had to make sure that like,
I gotta make sure this guy
does his fucking spin me out,
you know, hitting my car,
then I'll be fucked.
So it was this weird thing where he had
to be like super aggressive but also
cautious.
It was really exciting.
I know a lot of you guys
fast forward to any of that,
but I'm so fucking sold on
that sport. Um, I love it.
And I missed the fucking, I don't know
if there was a moto GP thing about,
what is it? Mark? Mark has his fucking,
he's running away with the thing. Um,
but it's still some of the best
racing. And next, next April,
I got to carve out some time. I want
to go to that Moto GP race in Austin.
But anyways, let's plow
ahead here everybody. Um,
okay.
So next thing I wanted to talk about,
oh, well we'll talk about football here.
So yesterday, the only
game I really watched, um,
was the, uh, the Patriots
versus the bears because, uh,
I only got so much time in
my day now and um, you know,
I had to make up for that time.
I was away and my,
my wife didn't tell me when I was on
the road was saying to my daughter when
she's at that age, she was actually
missing me. Like walking around,
it's going that, that I wasn't
there, fucking broke my heart. So,
um, anyways, I dunno.
So I gotta I gotta Work
Smarter is what I've learnt.
So I was just like, all right, this
is football Sunday, I'm finally home.
So what I did was I went out to breakfast
to my lovely wife, my beautiful child,
and I just tape the
Patriots game. And when, um,
my daughter took a nap, I I fucking
watched the bears patriots game,
you know,
it took me like maybe like an hour and
15 minutes to watch it because I had the
whole thing recorded up until like
the final five minutes. And uh,
here's what I would do if I
was the offensive coordinator
of the fucking bears.
All right. That mixture bisky I don't
know if I said his name right. All right.
Very mobile quarterback and all of that.
But at this point in his career,
anything beyond 17 yards as
far as if it's like a pass,
he sees not accurate at all. They haven't
said that. I remember Tom Brady is this.
Secondly, the second year after he won
the super bowl is deep ball was not good.
Okay?
I'm not saying it was Mitch Dubiski bad.
I'm just saying you can get better at it.
The guy can fucking throw it. 60 yards.
As we saw in the last play of the game,
he's just got to make sure that there's
somebody underneath it with the same
Jersey says.
So I didn't understand why didn't they
just dinking dumped their way down the
field, had that Cohen kid or
whatever coming out of the backfield.
He was killing us all day,
but they kept trying to throw like a 20
yard fucking pass and like I gotta be
honest with you.
I mean really it wasn't even close.
Should a dentin dunk their way down
the field and occasionally just send
somebody deep,
Have Mitch air the fucking thing out
just to keep everybody honest. All right.
And then you can utilize his eyes
running an ability because we grew really
couldn't stop the guy.
I'll tell you what was annoying,
but I really hate is when a quarterback
acts like they're going out of bounds
and everybody pulls up and then
the guy gets another 20 yards.
I think on the next fucking play you
ought to be able to like the guy up.
Alright?
It's a country fucking move
and everybody's slow eyes
like he's Barry Sanders.
Yeah, no it isn't. It isn't. Um,
okay.
But um,
one thing I will say if haven't sat
here and watched the ridiculous level of
celebrating that goes on in baseball now
and in football, especially in baseball,
like, dude, I don't fucking get it.
These guys had doubles and they're
doing synchronized celebrating with the
people in the dugout and back in the day,
you never did that shit.
If you fucking did that, your buddy who's
bad. Next we'll be looking at you like,
are you out of your fucking mind?
And then he'd take one of the head,
the pitcher just through it, the next
pattern and it was just acceptable.
Now you've got these guys, they're
going up there. They got the face guard,
they got the elbow pad,
they got the Shin Guard,
they're hanging all
over the fucking plate.
I would just love to hear what
like Nolan Ryan would say about
about that,
and then there's celebrate and they
hit a single and they're doing little
fucking jazz hands. People that dug
out at that point at each other.
They're fucking thumping that chest.
You need think they just won the game.
That's what kills me.
Like who's that guy on
on the fucking patriots?
I don't know anybody's name
anymore. I got a kid, right?
The fucking guy catches
the football on a kickoff.
I Dunno what it was. They're like scores
like 10 to three Isam, shit like that.
Seven to three, I can't remember. He
runs up to about the 15 yard line,
gets fucking drilled, coughs it up,
and that other bears fit player,
by the way,
just fucking Johnny on the spot just
catches the ball and he gives them like he
coughs it up,
bears get the ball and like the 15
yard line going and fucking score.
All right. Absolutely, totally fucked up
as the kick returner and then either the
next character, a couple of kicks later,
same guy catches the ball,
he runs down the field,
goes all the way for a touchdown,
slows down and like the eight yard line
to high five another fucking Patriot
before he goes over. The goal line
is slow as humanly fucking possible.
He's sitting there high five and like
he's up in that game. It's like, dude,
that just made you even,
you need to run another one back
and run into the fucking end zone.
I don't know if they turned, they drive
me. He's got world class speed. Yeah,
we'll tell him to fucking
stand on his head.
Maybe some of that world class speed
will trickle down into his fucking
brainstem.
That's like when fucking a tripit ski was
running all over the fucking field and
then we finally to sack him and one of
the Patriots does the shush thing to the
crowd, like he's been doing it all day.
That reminds me way back in the day,
Jerome Bettis was the king of that.
Granted he's a fucking hall of Famer,
so I'm probably wrong on this,
but I would watch that guy and he
would live like 30 yards on 20 carries.
And then in like the fucking
beginning of the fourth quarter,
he'd finally ripped one off for 30 yards
and then he'd get up and start fucking
stopping around. Like you've been
doing it all day. I guess it's,
it's just a, I think it's like
a generation gap type of thing.
I've always liked the guys.
They'd score a touchdown,
they give the ball back to the referee.
You know,
I just feel like everybody
now is aware that, um,
if you make a good play,
it's going to end up on Instagram.
So you gotta you gotta throw a little
more fucking mustard on it and then maybe
everybody will forget about the,
the rest of the fucking game.
I have no idea. Anyways,
plowing ahead here. Um,
okay.
What do I got here? I'm trying to
look for the fucking advertising here.
All right. Oh, Jesus Christ. I didn't,
or the Kate Upton thing that
I got was fucking hilarious.
I didn't realize she was married
to, what's his face on the,
on the Houston Astros. Um,
anyways, my bookie, everybody,
my bookie,
sure watching football is fun,
but it's more entertaining when you
have some action on the games. Guys,
you heard me talking about this for
weeks and some of you are still on the
sidelines. Uh, whether
you're an expert or a rookie,
you should be betting at my bookie.
If you're the kind of guy that likes to
bet a little and when a lot like playing
the numbers on roulette,
you can create a big par lake.
I don't know why they use that roulette.
Okay.
Analogy.
You know when you gamble,
you're actually trying to like use
your brain roulette. Is that right?
A Big Dyke blog to my blog
too, bro. Fuck it back.
Great.
No,
when you bet on sports,
she got his system anyways,
pick three teams to win and if he hit
all three, could turn $100 into $600.
There's so much to bet on.
Playoff baseball, basketball,
hockey, primetime fights,
and more. I recommend these guys because
I really trust him. Uh, evidently my book,
my book. What the fuck? I never
said that. I just read that my book,
He has been in business for years.
They've got great online reviews and
their mobile site is easy to use. My,
he is offering a 100% bonus
for the last time this year.
That's right.
Okay.
You've been thinking about pat placing,
placing a picc all season,
but haven't manned up yet.
Huh?
You're not gambling. What
are you a coward? Well,
it's time to make ti a time to
make your move. Jesus Christ.
After Sunday's kickoff, you can kiss the
bonus. That bonus. Goodbye. Sorry people,
I left my laptop in Baltimore,
which I know sounds like a fucking
tribe called quest song. Um,
okay.
They left their wallet and Elsa Gundo.
I left my laptop in Baltimore. Um,
and it's being shipped to me.
So I'm reading this off my phone and
not matter how big I make the font,
I can't read it.
Also,
make sure to follow at bet my
bookie on Twitter or Instagram.
They personally respond
to every mentioned in DM.
Not to mention that they've given away
nearly $10,000 in free money to their
followers this football season.
You'll be the first to know as soon
as new odds and props are posted,
log onto my bookie right now.
Don't miss out on your last opportunity
to collect the industry's biggest bonus.
Use Promo Code [inaudible] and you'll get
your first deposit matched 100% that's
Promo Code Burr. You play, you win,
you get paid or you lose,
you pay and you get
yelled at by your wife.
Always got to show you the other
side of it, people. All right,
Anne v m t movement
has come far from being crowdfunded
kids working out of a living room.
Oh, that's how two broke
college kids started a startup.
They were crowdfunded. Uh,
in the past year. They've not only
introduced a ton of new watches,
watch collections for both men and women.
Why did it say women and men?
This is the male patriarchal
system in advertising,
but also expanded to sunglasses and
fashion forward bracelets for her.
Talk about your favorite new style
and it's features. Suggestion,
revolver collection. Well,
I guess they look like guns.
Talk about entrepreneurship,
what it takes for a company
to reach exponential growth,
our personal experience with it,
et Cetera. You know, you know,
I'm not smart enough to do that.
Moving watches start at just
95 bucks at a department store.
You're looking at four to
500 bucks movement figured
out that by selling online,
they were able to cut out the
middleman and retail markup,
providing the best possible price.
Classic design, quality construction,
styled minimalism.
If relevant.
Talk about how a smartwatch is overly
intrusive on life with notifications,
text messages, emails, et
Cetera. Not only, not only that,
he just microchipped
yourself for the second time
when you captain Kirk,
you just need to know what time it is.
A get 50% off today with free
shipping and free returns.
Free by going to mvmt.com/birth
see why movement keeps growing.
Checkout they're expanding collection.
Go to movement.com mvmt.com/burr
joined the movement.
Uh, look who's of you buddy. It's
simply safe. Well, we get a lot of them.
I'm gonna read this one and then take
a break. I'll go back to the podcast.
Simply safe home security is home
security that finally gets it right.
Simply safe started 10 years ago
with the mission to fix the industry.
They cut out contracts, middlemen,
and push the sales guys.
They made it easy to set up your
system with no handwrite wiring tools.
Your hand wiring our tools with simply
safe, you get professionally monitored,
24 seven protection for just $15 a month.
That's your home protection by police,
dispatch and fire dispatch.
Everyone loves this system.
Everyone loves it.
They love how it works and
how easy it is to use today.
Simply safe protects
over 2 million people.
They've won editor's choice awards
from CNE t PC magazine and wire cutter.
Go to simply safe bird.com today
to order your simply safe system,
you get a 60 day risk free trial.
That's simply safe.
burg.com simply safe bird.com s I m p l,
I. S. A F E. B U. R R d.
O. T. C. O. M. M. All right.
No you don't. You don't.
You put in the dot, right?
Is that how it works?
Is that Howard works? Um, anyways,
plowing ahead here.
What else did I want to talk about?
Looking at the notes on my phone.
Did I already lose it over here?
Oh, there it is. There
it is. There it is. Um,
so anyway, so I got to
tell you. So I took,
we took our daughter to a pumpkin patch
yesterday, which, you know, that's,
that's a big mom,
dad moment for you.
First Time you take your kid to a
pumpkin patch, right? So my wife's going,
she goes, uh, when do you want
to take it? You want to take her?
Sorry. Before her nap or after I go a
pumpkin patch seems more like a fall,
you know, afternoon type of things does.
She goes, all right, we'll do it after.
So anyways, we had gone to breakfast
in the morning and then we, uh,
we went to a would, she takes her
naps and now we're going to go.
So we ended up going to this
really nice part of town
out here in la. I don't want to
out this fucking thing. All right?
They say it's a pumpkin patch. Okay,
now I know I live in a fucking city,
but at the very least,
you know,
just try to fuck and recreate
some of sort of patch.
We show up to the God damn thing.
It's in the parking lot of a fucking cvs.
They've got a corner of it.
There's a god damn tent in there.
And when I tell you they had four
thousand four thousand fucking people
underneath that tent
and this fucking giant woman who she
was like this size of chief in one flew
over the cuckoo's nest screaming at
everybody that they had to keep this area
clear.
It's clear a what?
There's 4,000 of us in here.
They got fucking goats and dig got up.
They had a petting zoo in this, like
swear to God, this little section,
they threw some, hey, I
got to give it to them.
They threw some hay down over
the fucking blacktop to him.
And I'm sitting there like,
alright,
you know when life gives you lemons lag
going to the fucking pumpkin patch of a
fucking cvs who gives a shit. But my
wife is sitting there going like, like,
you know, this is why women are awesome
because they do the holidays right.
You know, they're just sitting there
like, you know, this isn't the fucking,
this is not a pumpkin patch,
but I will tell you this,
they had some of the best pumpkin's
I've ever fucking seen the Pumpkin's,
we're fucking ridiculous.
They were the kind of Pumpkin that
if there was a cookbook about shit,
you can make out a pumpkin.
These were the pump because
they would make the cover.
These were the sports illustrated
swimsuit models of fucking pumpkin.
So it wasn't all bad.
All right.
And that like six foot five woman yelling
and everybody was fucking hilarious
cause she was getting frustrated but
still trying to be nice, you know?
And she's into this fucking tent of God.
Damn head is almost touching
the top of the tent.
There was so much and I
didn't have any fucking money.
And somehow in there they had a little
ATM machine and I'm sticking my fucking
credit, my ATM card,
and they're going like,
there's no way this isn't
getting double swiped.
There's no way some Russian baron isn't
gonna try to fucking buys. I Dunno.
Oh fuck it.
Pen and pencil set for his ex wife with
whatever the fuck I have on my God damn
accountant account. So anyways, she
pulls the ripcord, she goes, no, no, no,
no, we're going to go to this
other one. So I'm like right,
no problem. Cause this is the new me.
I don't fight this shit. All right,
I've just decided I'm going to be a better
fucking husband and I'm just going to
argue less.
And when you really make the decision
that you're going to be a better husband,
they're the only real option is you
just going to agree with your wife.
Um,
that's really it to and in a lot of
women applaud that where if it went the
other way, like ladies, if
you want to be a happy wife,
just agree with your husband.
It would be considered like really
sexist and uh, they'd be a kept woman.
Does Stepford fucking wife or
whatever the hell he could Bridgeport,
it's some fucking town in Connecticut.
Wife, right? Hartford wife.
Um, anyway, Stanford, Stanford wife.
Is that what it is? I have
no idea. Um, yeah, you just,
you just fucking agree with
them. Alright. And that's,
it makes it, it makes it better because
that whole happy wife happy life. I mean
it's really like, it's a
joke I do on my act. I go,
it sounds cute cause it rhymes,
but it's a threat because it's literally,
if your wife isn't happy, nobody's going
to be happy. And that includes you.
You kid the fucking, yeah.
If y'all got a Goldfish,
it's gonna Start Rolling over on its side.
Like it's starting to die until
she gets into a better mood again.
So it's just like, okay,
let's just fucking,
let's just keep it happy.
That's so, all right.
So we drive over to this other one and
the old me would have been like, yeah,
it's a fucking pop.
Could get good fucking [inaudible] a
fucking no one wants to let game the,
I would have been the old me.
So I don't,
I just do what my wife says and
I get back in the car. Right.
Fucking drive over the other side
of town does next pumpkin patch.
So we pull into the next pumpkin patch.
There's no place to park.
It's fucking crazy. It's actually
in a field. This fucking rides.
There's a petting zoo. There's
actually room for it. Right?
I'm not a big petting zoo fan by the way.
All right.
All I'm thinking is fucking what does it
hoof and mouth disease often fucking a
goat horn, dizzy, whatever the
fuck it's called. Right. Um,
and not to mention,
they bring the Goddamn kids in there and
they're sitting there like walking up.
They got no respect.
The parents for these fucking goats,
they've had their horn sought off.
So now they're standing there, right?
Like, like, uh, like Luke
Skywalker without his lightsaber.
Now he's just some guy in a bar,
you know,
I'm a Jetta. Oh yeah. Let me
see some jet. I shit. Well,
you know, I'd love to, but uh,
you know, my light saber, the
battery, I got to recharge it.
Just hang out for a second. I'll fucking,
I'll have a sword fight with somebody.
You'd be impressed.
Right?
So we go in there and this just
people that just like their pet goats,
like their dogs and you see the goats,
the goats there, they're fucking annoyed.
One of the guys goes up and he's just
stroking the beard of this one goat where
I'm just like, you know, I'm not in
the social circles that goats here,
but that's gotta be some high
level fucking disrespect.
You know,
would you go into the fucking octagon
at the UFC and start tugging on the
fucking man bundle,
one of those fucking black
belt human weapon lunatics?
You wouldn't, this is
what they were doing. So
my wife keeps telling me to let my kid
pet the fucking things. And I'm like,
so I've just was holding onto her
and I went perpendicular to the goat.
You know,
if it's an alligator you want to come
straight on because they got to turn their
head to the side to fucking bite you.
She goes straight up and just fucking,
you know, pet it on the snap. I mean,
if we're really going
to do white people shit,
which is walk up to shit and act like
it's a fucking dog when it isn't,
that's basically what we
do in nature, right? So my,
see my wife getting frustrated,
like I'm being a helicopter parent.
I'm not a helicopter parent lifestyle,
but I don't say that. I'm like, all right,
you know why you fucking do it?
So she's,
she's bringing the kid in like all the
moms and they got the fucking goats eaten
this hae to try to keep them happy and
ignore the fact that people are stroking
that Goddamn beards,
right?
So all of these mothers are
approaching from the rear of the animal
and all I'm thinking is one of
these kids is going to take a, a,
a single or a double fucking leg
kick from one of these fucking, uh,
for one of these goats.
So I'm sitting there trying to eat,
just fucking go from the side.
So fortunately nothing happened.
And um, then all these people like,
hey, you want to go hit the food truck?
It's like your kid just fucking pet goat.
You're trying to get goat
pinkeye what do you, what do you,
what the fuck are you doing?
And they had chickens in
their chickens by the way,
he could tell that this,
these chickens were just for the petting
zoo because they were regular size.
Cause I was sitting there going like,
wow,
look how look how small
it's it's chest as you know,
as opposed to those fucking roided
up once. You know what I mean?
The pumping iron ones that are at
the grocery store. Um, anyways,
long story short, we fucking, before
we get into that, we pulled into this,
there's pumpkin patch and there's no
place to park. And my wife's goes,
which they have a valet and
I'm like at a pumpkin patch.
Like how, what happened to you that you
want to valet park at a pumpkin patch?
So we drive up this hill
way up this Goddamn hill and
there's all these signs in
the side of the road that just
say a no parking $50 ticket.
My wife's going like, it says
$50 a ticket. And I'm like,
well it's the price of doing business
and what the fuck do you want from me?
And then I'm looking at it and
it's written on construction
paper with the magic
marker. And I'm like, I really don't
think that's coming from the city. Right?
There's all these other people
parked here. Nobody has a ticket.
Okay.
So we just park.
So me,
me and Nia just start laughing
about this no parking sign
about how it's written on construction
paper with magic marker and we're going
down the hill.
And uh,
we ended up running into
somebody that knew us,
that got us in there
was a super long line.
And then we saw that there was actually
valet parking. It was like, ah, they want,
they want you to do the valet parking
that came from the valet people and the
regular parking so they could get your
money. See you wouldn't park for free.
And we ended up parking up. So we went in
there, we had the best fucking time. Uh,
people asked and they treated you like
a king. Can't thank, I'm not going to,
you know, say the name of
the fucking place. So what?
I always feel weird out in that shit,
but thank you so much for the way.
The petting zoo was awesome.
I was just an overprotective parent.
Evidently we got some
awesome fucking Pumpkin's.
I was pulling my daughter around in the
wagon and she's at the age now where she
wants to walk,
but once she got in the wagon,
she sat in the back corner
and was just chillin,
was leaning on one elbow and she had
her other arm fucking draped around like
she was fucking driving a low rider.
She absolutely loved it.
And uh,
I got to tell you when the
great dad moments of my life
was pulling a wagon with
my kid in it, with pumpkins all around
it. And I'm just thinking like, you know,
maybe that happy wife happy
life thing isn't a threat.
Maybe they just know when it comes
to this shit. The way I understand.
Um, I don't know. Some Guy Shit.
Okay,
so that's going to be my new thing.
All right.
You know, if you want to buy 47 fucking
pumpkin's for the kid Halloween party,
we're going to have, because it's
going to be great for their experience.
Then you know what?
We're going to get 47 fucking pumpkin's.
I've done all right.
I'm not going to pull a Lewis
Hamilton here and be like a, you know,
I don't know what happened
back there. I mean, uh,
I think we only need one pumpkin for
some reason we got 47, but uh, you know,
I mean, but it's tough
picking out pumpkins a tough,
I'm not going to do that.
She knows what the fuck's best
and we'll just, we'll just leave it at
that. We just leave us to that. I've done,
I remember long time ago going to a
cookout and talking to another husband.
He just, I said, so what'd you
say? What'd you say to her? Huh?
What'd you say to him? You
know, some bullshit. Right.
And he was just going, ah, man.
He goes, you know, Bill, he goes, I don't
have any more fight in me. And I was like,
first puzzle. But the, the amazing thing
was, was I heard the piece in his voice
and, and, and him and his wife
seem happy. So it was just like,
all right,
okay.
Maybe the problem here is me,
maybe because if the house was
run the way I was running it,
it would look like a bachelor pad
and that's not what kids need.
All right.
So I'm going to shut the fuck up and
make some pumpkin bread this week and
whatever my wife wants to do, I'm
just going to fucking do it. Hug Her,
tell her I love her and I'm going
to try that. I'm going to try that,
that road rather than fighting every
fucking goddamn thing and being a
that fucking guy in one of those hacky
Hollywood movies about cops being that
I'm getting too old for this shit,
being that guy ain't,
I ain't not fucking doing
it anyways. Um, all right.
Oh. And then another great
moment yesterday was a,
when we left the first pumpkin patch,
you know,
my daughter was enjoying walking around
so she was crying cause now she's back
in the fucking astronauts seat and
tried everything. I gave her my keys,
I gave him my hat, all of that shit.
And then uh,
that wouldn't work.
So I just started singing to her and then
Nia started singing along with me and
then our daughter's slowly stopped
crying and then was trying to sing along.
We were doing the, uh, you know,
where his point or where his point,
or here I am,
here I am.
And my daughter always sings along to a,
the run away. Like she knows that part.
So we get through all the fingers,
get through, where's, where is Mama,
where's Papa? You know, where's
my daughter? And then we run out,
she's done crying.
And then we just sang old McDonald had
a farm all the way to the next pumpkin
patch,
which was literally like a half hour away.
And what was funny was we ran out of farm
animals and I was doing like penguins
and giraffes because my wife
was, Neil was doing the, the,
the sounds of the animals and
who the fuck knows what a,
what a giraffe sounds like. So she would
be looking at me like, you can really,
you're going to throw that in my lap.
Like the guy on second base celebrating
the other guys at bat being like, Hey,
fuck it,
tone it down everybody.
But to take a 95 mile an hour
fast ball to my fucking Chin,
God over here. Um, and you know what,
it was a great guy, Dan Day.
We didn't have any fights,
so I think I discovered something,
um,
all these years of being
with my lovely wife,
evidently I was the
problem. Um, and with that,
let's do, um, let's read some of the,
uh, the fucking, the read the emails
here for the week this week. Um,
all right, bill, great email. Slowly, uh,
a Billy but munch.
Oh my apologies to Kate Upton.
I wasn't really trashing or I just thought
it was funny was I feel like that's
the last person I thought. Well who
would have chimed in? I did say that.
I thought it was cool that
she was a baseball fan.
So I just listened to you
Thursday podcast. Your ears
should have been on fire.
I yelled like a wild man.
Keep reading you dumb ass.
Keep reading while you were
looking up Kate Upton's bio,
if you only had read a little more,
you would have discovered Kate Upton
is married to Justin Verlander.
Look at Justin Verlander
crushing it on the field and off.
He's a sad or aunties a close up.
Um,
she's married to him and is currently
carrying their first child. Hey,
congratulations to them that Justin,
I learned something.
Happy wife, happy life. All
right, so when she got you,
got you got major league ballplayer
money and she's got her money too.
So when she wants 98 Pumpkin's,
which I also believe it's the
speedy of fastball. Just, you know,
just grab a second, third fucking
wagon. Just do it. I'm telling you,
you'll love the best day ever anyways
is currently carrying their first child.
So yeah, she's, she really
likes the Astros baseball.
Come on Billy bookworm. Don't make me
yell like that. It's hard on my heart.
And so always go fuck yourself.
All right. I'm an idiot. Um,
I thought it was cool that you, I just
thought she was a baseball fan anyway.
I'm always the worst. All right.
Michelin Stars. Oh my God.
Am I going to get trashed for
everything I said last week? Bill,
I was listening to you Thursday afternoon
podcast and hurts you bring up the
Michelin Stars for food.
And I had the same reaction some years
back when I first heard about it.
For those you who didn't listen,
like I taught Michelin Stars was,
was separate from Michelin tires
like the way a mackintosh stereo,
like the best turntable. One of
the best out there, arguably, um,
is different from Macintosh computers
and it's spelled differently,
but evidently it was the same people.
And I'm like,
why am I listening to the
people who make radial tires?
So I don't fucking hydroplane tell
me where I should go. Get some,
uh, beef balling off. Um, so anyways,
he said I had the same reaction or she
said back when I first heard about it,
uh, like wait, it's the
same guys that do the tires.
So I had to find out why a tire company
became the standard for fine dining.
Um,
turns out the founders who are French,
so I automatically love him.
Started the tire company in 1900 when
there were only about 3000 cars in the
entire country.
So to help drivers develop road trips,
which would mean increase car sales
and also increased tire sales.
They started a guide that included maps,
how to change a tire,
where to get gas and
places to eat and sleep.
Eventually they branched into
fine dining in the 1920s or so,
this has got to be the most
informative and interesting.
A email I've gotten as
far as like correcting me.
The Kate Upton one,
one might have been the most hilarious
considering all you asked or friends knew
why she was chime in it anyways.
A one star means it's a very good
restaurant in it's category two stars is
excellent cooking worth a detour.
Three stars is exceptional
cuisine worth a special journey.
And I even think like that is um,
like all of those are uh,
the way they're described
are being extremely humble
because if he get any star
as far as, I mean, I don't too much about
it, but like if you get three stars,
you one of the best
restaurants in the world. Um,
so if you get one year, a third of the
best restaurant in the world, I mean,
I'm going to fucking eat there anyways.
Most restaurants don't even get the one
stars. So one stars pretty damn solid.
There you go. Always. Sorry. Anyways,
there is actually a one star restaurant
right down the street from the comedy
cellar,
a on Macdougal called Minetta tavern.
I've eaten there. You've probably
walked by this place thousands of times.
If you haven't been there, it's
definitely worth the stop in, uh,
think it opened in the 1930s.
Not Stuff. You're pretentious.
Really old school place
order the Black Label Burger.
I promised the Burger and fries
are going to be excellent.
I'm doing that next time I'm in New York,
which I'm going to be when I play
Madison Square Garden on November 7th.
Um, anyways, that's the Michelin Story.
Checkout Moneta if you haven't
before. Hey, you know what?
These are two really great
informative emails. I love it.
Thank you very much. A Hey, let me,
let me finish the last two reads
of the advertising here real quick.
You guys want to hear me read out loud?
Do you want to hear it be entertaining
again and then I'll go back to saying
dumb shit about stuff and then you guys
can correct me on the next podcast.
A dollar shave club to dude,
the fucking red sox are in the world
series playing the fucking Los Angeles
Dodgers. You know, usually they go
to the world series. I'm like, fuck,
if I was home I would go.
Now they're playing the team,
my hometown of God dammit.
I'm going to try to go to one of
those gangs and I will be not,
I will not be wearing any red sox shit
because it's just not fun on the west
coast.
Okay.
There's no fucking respect or anything.
You people try to kick the
shit out of here. It's, it's,
it's Philadelphia Times 900.
I've had a problem at dodger stadium.
I had a problem at a chargers game.
Um,
and I've only heard shit duffing good
about fucking 49 or raider games.
And it's just like, they, they just don't
get it. Sports fans out here really,
they just don't get it. It's
just, it's like violent.
And, um, so I just go there.
I don't wear any of this shit and I
just, I just leave it at that. But like,
people out here just [inaudible] there's
so much shit that's great about out
here, but the sports culture is
fucking horrific. So that's my
warning to anybody. Any red sox fan coming
out here for a dodger game, you know,
I'm not saying 100% something's
going to happen, but uh, you know,
it's kind of Nice not to have
brain damage. Wouldn't you say?
I would just leave you fucking shit
at home and silently fucking chair.
I dress like a fucking a undercover cop
when I go to the Games out here, right?
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody Dollar Shave Club has everything
you need to feel and smell your best
and you never have to go to
the store up. Oh, by the way,
if you're the fucking asshole
who stands up and points,
you know when you're in the
poisoned posing team stadium,
you're a fucking moron.
All right? And that's because they deliver
everything you need right to you do a,
and they keep you fully stocked on
what you use so you don't run out.
Here's how it works. Dollar Shave Club
has everything you need to get ready.
No matter what you're getting ready for.
They have you covered head to toe for
your hair, your skin and your face.
You name it,
they have it.
And they have this new program where they
automatically keep you stocked up, uh,
on the products you use.
You determine what you
want and when you want it.
And it shows up right at your door,
uh,
from once a month to once every six
months plus with their handsome discount.
The more you buy, the more
you save. And Right now,
dollar shave club has a bunch of
starter sets you can try for just $5,
like their oral care kit. After that, uh,
the restock box ships regular
sized products at regular price.
Get your start a set for just $5 right
now@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr A.
I'll look stamps.com
everyone last re lastly,
but not leastly a stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for any letters or
packages at your convenience. 24,
seven print postage for any small mail.
If for any male class right from your own
computer, the exact amount of postage,
every time,
never or overpay again,
stamps.com saves you time and money
which you use to grow your business.
stamps.com brings all the amazing services
of the U s postal service right to
your fingertips. Buy and print official
US postage for any letter, any package,
any classes, mail using your
own computer and printer stamps.
Saw Car makes it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps.com we'll even help you decide the
best class of mail based on your needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage
meter and there are no long term
commitments.
And right now you too can enjoy stamps.com
stamps.com servers with a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus postage and a digital sale scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com
enter
burr.
All
Right,
back to the reeds here.
Um,
no, not the reeds. Go back to the
emails. All right, here we go.
Kate Upton and Michelin Stars
car for a high school kid.
All right, let's see this.
Hey there, Billy bronco. Hey,
how about those new Broncos that are
coming back? Huh? Those looks sweet.
Um, I worked in a garage during
summers of high school and college.
Not only do you see, uh, what cars
aren't shit under the hood.
When I worked in car,
I literally went to the fantasy of buying
one of those Broncos and the fantasy
included my wife saying, absolutely,
Bill, get one. You know what?
I actually tried to talk her into letting
me buy one of those old GMC RVs from
the 1970s into the 80s,
and I wanted it in that palm desert green
and I was going to have to do to build
my truck,
make this fucking thing.
I was actually considering have a d
all electric and then hiring a driver.
Whenever I had a fucking road Gig,
I just had that thing driving around.
I'd fly to where it was
and do a run a gigs. Um,
and we would just be in there and
we'd have a fucking humor door.
And a fridge for some ice cold beer and
I put on fucking 9 million pounds and my
wife was just like, no, you're not
doing that. And I was just like, okay.
And it's got, because I
swear to God, if she didn't,
I would have the shit that I would
have. You know what I mean? I would,
I would argue that I would have one of
the weirdest fucking car collections ever.
Cause I would,
I would own one of those.
Yeah.
Um,
I like station wagons.
I'd have one of those fucking Mercedes
Benz AMG fucking station wagons.
MMM.
You know what? You know what
one of these days I'll actually,
I'll give you like my top 10 fucking
cars cause I really got to sit down and
think about it. I like those fucking
those, those GM member per lookup, GM,
General Motors Pereda progress.
Okay.
And look at those, those, whatever.
What the fuck that thing called?
Yeah,
just look that up.
Whatever that vehicle was called,
it was like a fucking living room
and a boss all at the same time.
It had a spiral staircase that you
walked up the parade, a progress,
check that thing out.
MMM.
Anyways, plowing ahead here. Let me,
let me finish reading this thing here.
MMM.
Not only do you see what I would have
stretch limos from the 1950s I have a
1955,
uh,
Chrysler imperial stretch limo or maybe
one of those ones that like John Lennon
and Elvis had and world leaders
had that was made by Mercedes,
the 1960s that really boxy looking one.
MMM
yeah.
All Weird Shit.
I wouldn't have a Shelby Mustang and a
fucking Hemi this and a Hemi that fuck
all that. That's all baby boomers. Shit.
I have no interest in any of that stuff.
I like that fucking weird shit.
I like those Nash.
I liked that fucking BMW that
had like three wheels in the,
in the full front of
the car would open up.
He had to move out the steering wheel.
I don't all shit like that.
Now there's gotta be somebody out there
with a car collection like that that you
can tell me where I can go look
at all those cars. Cause I,
I love all of that Shit,
man.
Okay.
All right. Uh, my advice for
the, uh, anyways, oh, the kid,
the kid who wanted to buy the
car. All right, let's start over.
I worked in a garage during
summers of high school in College.
Not only do you see what cars
aren't shit under the hood,
but also cars that look lame real fast.
Um,
my advice for that kid is to get something
with low mileage from the 90s jeeps,
lightweight pickups,
and anything you can find parts for and
anything where you open the hood and the
parts are identifiable.
Don't get a dodge neon or a shitbox.
Find something that looks new inside,
inside and out.
Get the oil changed every 3000 miles
and have it as long as you want it.
There you go. I used to do that. I,
that's one of the big things. Um,
okay.
Changing points when I was a
kid was I learned how to, uh,
change the oil in the car, which
is really simple, but it's huge.
I would do it every 2,500 miles.
I remember being in back east,
it'd be freezing fucking cold out and he
had to do that thing where it, you know,
I tried it the first time when the engine
was ice cold and the oil was coming
out like syrup. So you'd have to start
the car up, let it run a little bit.
We'd heat it up, but not too much where
all of a sudden then it'd be fucking hot.
But even then that wasn't bad. You just
go inside for like fucking a half hour.
And um,
okay.
I, and I had a little
place down by the, uh,
the firehouse that used to take the
recycled oil and I come down there and I'd
dump the shit in there. It
was fucking beautiful. Um,
I learned how to change the fuel filter
air filters, one of the easiest things,
fuel filter, uh, got a
grease gun, the loop job,
all that. So you didn't get all
the squeaks and all that shit.
Just basic maintenance like, and
then I would bring it in. Um,
I never learned how to
adjust a carburetor.
I always got nervous with
that shit and I would just,
mmm.
I do all of that. Although, however,
one time I got in patient taking a fuel
filter off and I snapped it off of the
fucking fuel line,
so then I had to get it towed over there
and I told the guy over there what I
did and he said I didn't communicate it
right and I had the fuel filter sitting
on the bench seat and he went out there
to start it up and gas when all over the
fucking engine and we had a fucking
engine fire. That's what he said.
We had a fire. I was like, no
dude, you had a fucking fire.
And then he fucking yelled at me and shit
and like, like I was going to sue them.
He goes,
oh,
they're not going to start fucking doing
a bunch of work on a God damn car with
a hundred something thousand fucking
miles on it and just yelling at me.
I remember looking at the guy like,
okay,
dude, I've, and bringing you a gift is
my fucking car will be here forever.
This is how you're going to treat me.
I'm not trying to be a fucking asshole,
but I did not say that to them.
Okay.
So I remember my dad told me,
he goes,
you go down there and
you make sure you pay.
So there's a record that your car
was there and not, and sure enough,
I went down and the guy said, no
charge. I said, no, I'll pay for it.
And he gave me a look because he knew
that I knew what the fuck he was doing.
And that's the last time I
brought my car over there,
had it fixed somewhere else.
And Long Story Short,
at one point I had an engine fire and
it fucking burned down to the ground.
But that was years later. That was
my first vehicle to 83 Ford Ranger.
Um, anyways, to be honest,
the insecurity never came.
Yeah.
Uh, wait a sec. Oh, it's a different,
different fucking email. Oh,
okay. So that's, that's that guy
suggested he was too skinny, too tall.
Here's the thing about
the insecurity. Um, Bill,
I am what you would call a
goofy looking bitch. Five 11,
like 135 pounds and super awkward.
I have a pretty face, so I'm told,
but I've always felt weird about my body.
Are you fucking kidding me?
If you got into fashion, they tell
you to lose 20 pounds. Five 11,
one 35. You sound lean
and mean to me. Be Honest.
The insecurity never came from me,
but from other people by
earliest memory of yeah.
And that's probably their insecurity
cause you're probably taller than a lot of
guys.
Um,
my earliest memory of being made
to feel weird about my body,
I'm assuming this is a woman.
Okay.
Oh, they signed it.
Olive oil. All right. Uh,
my earliest memory of being made to
feel weird about my body was when I was
eight and a teacher said,
yeah,
I'm too skinny and look weird.
Yeah, that's old school shit. Uh,
people used to do that. I shot up in
heights since then and I've always,
always been mocked for either the
height, weight or both. As a consequence,
I've developed somewhat
of a complex about it.
I've been suicidal about it
before, honestly. Oh Jesus Christ.
Don't take it to that level.
You've got the supermodel body.
Um,
okay.
But then I'll watch some
video about a burn victim
and then feel like a real sack of shit.
All right, so you got some perspective.
I'm a girl by the way. Forgot to mention
that. And when I was in high school
school,
I got bullied by this short guy.
He said I was turning into a man once
and I honestly cried my eyes out.
Oh God. Because you know what it
is? He's a little fucking run.
And that's, that's the
thing. If, if anything,
anybody in high school listening to that,
like one of the best things you
can learn in life is that so much,
so many things that other people say.
It really has nothing to do with you,
even if they're saying it about you and
has to do with the other person and how
their parents suck or they feel bad
about their own life. So, you know,
like if you want people to not say mean
Shit to you, uh, walk around happy,
have a happy look on yourself,
on your face. Like, you know,
go out and enjoy yourself and you won't
believe the fucking negative attention
that you'll get.
MMM.
And one of the great joys in
life is the day you realize that,
that it has nothing to do with you.
And you learn to just filter
all of that stuff up. Um,
you have five, 11, one 35. I
mean, I'm telling you like,
yeah,
there's,
there's a lot of women that are going to
fucking hate you because of your height
and your build because it's going to
be hard for them to keep weight off.
He got a tremendous advantage.
Everything that all the
clothes you're going to put on,
there's a reason why models are so
tall and all that because they look
absolutely stunning in the clothes.
And then they sell it to all of all the
short fucking people out there and then,
and then they never look right.
Um, anyways, she said, uh,
my question to you is,
hi,
do I get to a point in life
where you don't give a shit?
When anyone says I get that,
I'm thin. But honestly,
it's just the weight my body likes.
I'm not unhealthy at all.
I have no health issues and my doctor
isn't word. Yeah. And, and the, the,
the older you get,
you're going to,
you're going to look great and all the,
that little run two made funny you.
There's nowhere for it to go except
for his fucking man tits. Um,
what should I do next time
someone says something to me, uh,
I'm 22 and people at work feel
comfortable enough to say shit like,
did you have eating issues as a kid?
Jesus Christ.
Even a complete stranger
who is asking for my help,
no less took it upon herself
to tell me I look anorexic.
Um, yeah, no, that's, that's
all other people's issue.
I feel like people think they can get
away with shit like this because I'm not
fat. You think I should just tell
people to fuck off? Only thing is,
if I do,
that'll be,
I'll be in an argument pretty
much one to two times per week.
Thanks a bunch and I love,
I love you and Nia wish you
and the Munchkin the best.
Go fuck yourself a olive oil. All right.
You've got a great sense of humor.
Just seeing your olive oil, there's a
bunch of shit you can do. All right.
Um, I dunno, I,
one of the things I used to do when
I used to go out after shows and when
somebody said like mean stuff
to me, I would just go, uh,
you got something between your
teeth and they never did. Right.
But it would just make
himself self conscious.
They'd immediately shut their mouth and
put that tongue up over their teeth and
then just fucking walk away.
Um,
you can do that and just say, I
appreciate that and just, you know,
offer them a piece of Gump,
you know,
make it seem like they have bad breath.
There's little things like that to
turn it back around on them. Um,
okay.
I don't, I don't, you know, you know
what really, what is really going to be,
cause then, you know, I'm also suggesting
that you kind of be mean to them.
What you're going to have to do is just,
you know,
learned to like how you look. That's
it. And just really know that,
um, that's all about, and I know
you're at work, but you know,
if a guy said something to you, I mean
it's easy to be like, just be like,
you know,
I recently heard that a lot of things
that people say mean about you has nothing
to do with you. It has to do with them.
That's too long. Just to be like, sir,
are you saying that to me?
Cause you're actually concerned or is
it because your dick is the size of a
fucking peanut? I don't know what
the fuck you can go with Dick size.
That's always good. All right. This is
some old school yard bully shit. Yeah,
just go with the obvious. They're
going with the obvious on you. Oh,
you can talk about my weight and I can
talk about that giant fucking potato you
call a fucking nose in
the middle of your face.
Okay.
You know, you know it's going
to keep growing your ears,
your nose just keep growing.
You're going to look like Jimmy
Duranti by the time you're 35.
You don't know who the fuck
he is. We'll look them up.
You can't now. Um, yeah, but,
uh,
I dunno.
Yeah.
I, I mean, I'm going to give you stand
up lines. You can't save him at work.
If some woman said you'd said you
are, you anorexic and just say, no,
I just know how to push myself away from
the table. Your pudgy con, you know,
there's that, you can do that. But
I think it's really more important.
It just accepting the fact that here's
the thing, your metabolism will slow down.
As you get older, you'll fill out
a little bit more. And you know,
I mean, when I was 22, I
was a fucking rail myself.
And I look at the beautiful ball
that Donna said, hi, I'm now at 50.
Um,
okay.
I Dunno. Look at me. I started losing
my hair. I didn't go out and fucking,
you know, try to start moving shit
around up there. I just said, fuck it.
I shaved my head. I just
am who I am. And, you know,
people call me a bald cut
now and it makes me laugh.
I actually take it as a
term of endearment. Uh,
I like how I look and I know
I, I, I'm, I'm not, you know,
I'm not a good looking guy, but I
fucking, I, I like it. I liked that.
I look like a fucking freak.
It's, and I actually enjoy aging.
I bought this fucking old man's
sweater the other day and my wife goes,
why you can't put that on you look
like you're fucking an old man. I go,
I am an old man.
Let me be an old man at where my old
man's sweater put around the house and
fucking a sitting on the
back porch smoking a scar,
thinking a glory days.
You're 22 years old,
you got your whole life ahead of you.
You're going to run into somebody who's
going to realize how fucking beautiful
you are.
And I got to admit something,
the fact that everybody gives
a shit about the way you look,
you're going to have a great
sense of humor and you're
gonna laugh a lot in life.
And that's gonna keep you young. Said,
God bless you and you five 11 body,
hundred 35 pounds and everybody else
can go fuck themselves. And with that,
that's the podcast and the rest of you
can go fuck yourselves and I'll check in
on Thursday.